Policy shaping.
>> Policy shaping.
>> Did you make up that word because
I'm not sure I understand what that
word means.
>> So I did not make up the word policy
and I did not make up the word shaping.
>> No I know that.
[LAUGH] No, I'm sorry that
the combination of those two words.
>> Well I'm not going to say I
made it up although maybe I did,
one of the papers that we're
going to read is actually a paper
that I was a part of the author team on.
And it's all about introducing
the notion of policy shaping.
And it's really a very simple idea,
it's sort of what I just described, that
what human beings are actually doing
is giving you direct policy advice.
And so they're trying to shape what
the policy should be directly,
as opposed to trying to say something
about what rewards ought to be.
Does that make sense?
>> Yeah I think so.
I mean I guess now, before I was
thinking about shaping differently.
But now it's sort of feeling
like sculpting to me,
like you have a policy out there and
you're going to apply pressure and
smoothing in different places to
have it be a little bit different.
>> Right, so think about it this way.
There's actually I think
a direct way of doing this.
When you do policy shaping,
what have you actually done?
What you've actually done is you've
taken whatever the reward function was
in say some particular state or
some particular action and
let's say was zero.
And what you said is no, this is
the wrong answer, the wrong value,
it should not be zero here.
It should actually be something else,
it should be, well I don't know,
three so you've actually replace
the original reward function
R with another reward function R prime
instead this is actually the reward
function that you should
be learning over.
And that's really what reward
shaping does for you, right?
I mean, if you think back to the
examples that you were giving with all
the reward shaping, you were
replacing reward values, agreed?
>> Yeah, though in the case where we
were doing potential base shaping,
we also had to make sure that whenever
we sprinkled some positive reward in,
there was negative reward someplace
else to balance it out, so
you didn't get new positive
reward cycles happening.
>> Right now that's true but regardless
of where you sprinkle them and
what kind of constraints you put up you
still took what was originally a reward
value of something like zero and
replaced it with another reward value
>> I agree with that.
>> Plus three, minus three,
seven, doesn't matter.
So you change the reward function.
So in exactly the same way policy
shaping is about changing the policy.
There's some policy that
the agent currently has and
you're saying actually in this state,
rather than whatever it was you
think you should do,
you should do in fact this.
So maybe I'm confirming what you already
had, maybe I'm telling you to do
something different, but regardless
I'm overriding your policy function.
In the same way that in reward shaping
you're overriding the reward function.
>> Okay, that makes sense.
>> Right, so this is what
policy shaping is all about and
it happens to line up with,
it turns out in practice,
the way people are actually
trying to convey information.
And so then the real question is,
what do you do with this?
How do I take this information
that's being given,
if it's not being given in the form of
rewards, we know how to do that, but
it's actually being given
in the form of a policy.
What should I actually do about it?
>> So I was interpreting what
you described as saying,
if a person gives positive feedback for
an action in a state and it's not
the action that the agent would have
taken that state, then just replace it.
Just make a modification of the policy
so that, that's the action that's taken.
Is that the way to do it?
>> Well, ideally that is
what you would do, right?
If a person tells you, look,
you should go up here, or
you should eat a ghost here,
you should just do it.
But that actually requires something be
true, which as the lawyers would say,
assumes facts not in evidence.
And that is,
that the person's actually right.
What if the person's wrong?
>> Yeah, but certainly we should at
least have that as our assumption.
I mean, if we don't think the person
is right then this is a really
easy thing to do policy keeping.
Just ignore the person.
>> But what if the person is
right most of the time, but
can occasionally be wrong?
>> I see.
>> But what if the person's right but
actually meant to say at
the time step before?
>> I see, so maybe there's a way to
use all these different things as
evidence and
then to combine them together to get,
I don't know kind of a best guess
as to what the right answer is.
>> Exactly and that's why it's
policy shaping and not policy doing.
So I'm going to try to give you a little
quiz and see if we can kind of work out
what the right thing to do is under
the circumstances, where a person
might tell you to do something and
might not always be right about it.
Seem fair?
>> Yeah.